people are lining up to try food that
you've probably never seen before a
giant pickle stuffed with hot cheetos
and queso
this pickle has gone viral for obvious
reasons but what does it taste like and
can it possibly be delicious i'm also
trying a cheeto covered turkey leg and a
fully loaded bloom and onion to see
which food will come out on top
the arizona state fair has existed
longer than arizona has even been a
state it started in 1905 and has become
arizona's largest public event the state
fair is known for having a huge variety
of food options and i tried a lot of
them including a two foot long corn dog
a giant cinnamon bun and some delicious
homemade fudge but the state fair is
most popular for serving up a huge
variety of hot and spicy foods and all
three of my top dishes were super spiced
up
[Music]
turkey legs are a fair staple but this
one has a bit of a twist and is covered
in hot queso and hot cheetos
hot cheeto foods are extremely popular
at the arizona state fair and the hot
cheeto turkey leg is no exception here
at the arizona state fair we're gonna
sell over a truckload of turkey legs and
that's a lot of birds that are flapping
around
each leg weighs about two pounds and is
around 1450
calories i think this is gonna have tons
of flavor i mean how can it not it's
huge okay let's do this
wow okay
it is turkey but it has christmas ham
vibes when i say that i mean it's super
smoky a little sweet then the spice
creeps up in the back of your throat i
kind of like it i'm vibing with it all
together lots of flavor but not too much
cheese is one of my all time favorite
foods and this turkey leg is covered in
it but so is our next contender so we
will have to see how they compare
similar to our fan favorite our hidden
gem is another classic fair staple with
a twist a bloom and onion spiced up
arizona style with hot queso bacon and
jalapenos the history of the bloom and
onion is widely debated but legend has
it that it was invented in new orleans
at russell's marina grill back in the
mid-80s since you can't copyright food
it quickly became popularized through
outback steakhouse and then it flooded
state fairs across the country
at bishops bloom and onion they
typically go through around 1200 onions
per day
fully loaded this bad boy comes out to
be 2 000 calories
okay let's try this out
whoa
i mean
can you go wrong with fried onions the
answer is no these are double coated and
fried so they are crispy the onion has a
give a fight to it really strong flavor
but not too strong the ranch ties it
together with a tang it's perfect for
sharing you have tons of flavor
i don't have any friends right now so
i'm gonna eat this by myself
okay my first two foods were super
spiced up versions of classic pear items
but my last contender is new to the
state fair this year and has never been
seen before
after trying all the food at the fair we
decided we had to go back to biggie's to
show you this spicy pickle just like the
other two contenders it is super spiced
up with hot cheetos hot queso and
jalapenos i got in the kitchen to make
one myself why don't you grab the
biggest one you can find yeah that one
right there that's a good one this is a
good pickle all right so we're going to
cut off the top because we're pouring it
right you want to go as close as you can
to the outer skin without poking it
through without poking yourself okay so
pour this yep
into it yeah kind of tap it down there
you go
honestly our pickle's gonna have a
gorgeous set of hair oops i'm drizzling
all over the place
am i done you're done okay
it is here the pickle i've been waiting
to try this
honestly it looks way more impressive
than i thought it was going to be
i'm nervous okay
whoa
let me break it down for you we got the
pickle it's got a tang to it then we got
this creamy cheese which is so delicious
and the flaming hot cheetos add a crunch
and that spice add the jalapenos this is
actually a very well-rounded pickle you
guys i honestly really like this it's
got the cheese it's got the spice it's
got crunch it's got tang
uh it is really good really delicious i
would definitely try this again it is a
little bit of a mess though so you got
to be ready
wow i am full and i am happy i ate so
many delicious foods today and i did
pick a winner after really thinking it
through and the winner really surprised
me actually
the winner is the flaming hot queso
pickle
so when i saw that i'm eating a pickle i
was like a side dish i never thought of
a pickle as a main course and this
pickle was loaded with flavor not to
mention cheese is always a party i love
it i picked this one because it really
shocked me it had a ton of flavor and
it's really a dish that you can only get
at the arizona state fair well that's
all for the arizona state fair i will
see you guys next time be sure to stay
hungry
oh god
oh that's disgusting
[Music]